c'est une crise sanitaire importante et
qui a touché des familles et des enfants
et donc évidemment qui est extrêmement
grave
je note que ce groupe lactalis a
conservé un culte du secret qui n'est
plus tout à fait ce qu'on attend d'une
entreprise responsable au 21e siècle et
il a caché les auto contrôle l'état ne
pouvait pas deviner qu'on lui masquer
des choses et je note que l'état a réagi
très vite dès lors qu'il a eu
connaissance pour demander le retrait
des produits et pour procéder aussi à la
poursuite contre contre c'est contre ces
manoeuvres
donc il y a il y a eu une réaction de
l'état ensuite il y a eu vraiment un
problème dans la distribution qui a
remis certains produits alors qu'il ne
fallait pas les remettre
et ça c'est la responsabilité des
entreprises vous savez quand on a la
liberté de créer et d'entreprendre
ça va avec la responsabilité et la
responsabilité c'est aussi à sanctionner
et puis ce groupe qui a mis beaucoup de
temps pour s'excuser qui a des pratiques
un peu anciennes et à mon avis se prend
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle une une
crise en termes de communication mais
voyez quand on anticipe sur des
pratiques et bien on évite ce genre de
choses et notamment en étant beaucoup
plus prompte et beaucoup plus sérieux
sur les contrôles sanitaires
il y a des les enquêtes judiciaires qui
vont être ouverts puisqu'il ya un dépôt
de plainte et on verra ensuite la
reponsabilité de chacun mais je crois
que ce n'est quand même pas la
responsabilité de l'état qui est engagée
là mais bien celle du producteur et du
distributeur
en revanche cela n'exclut pas notamment
dans la loi à venir à la suite des états
généraux de l'alimentation à réfléchir à
des sanctions
par exemple plus importantes pour ce
type de pratique le principe d'une
commission d' enquête sur la sphère
lactalis et ce type d'affaires en
général a été actée à l'assemblée est ce
que vous pensez que la représentation
nationale peu
faire la lumière sur ce qui sur cette
affaire sachant qu'elle ne peut empiéter
sur des procédures judiciaires en cours
que ça sert à quelque chose cet angle
c'est aussi cette enquête
je pense que la commission d' enquête
sur lactalis est très utile parce que
elle peut d'abord déboucher sur une
meilleure compréhension de la situation
sans empiéter bien sûr sur l' enquête
judiciaire mais aussi sur des
propositions déboucher sur des
propositions pourquoi pas des
amendements à apporter à la loi que va
défendre
stéphane travert si il y à des
améliorations à apporter
donc je crois que nous sommes
typiquement dans le cas où le rôle du
parlement est utile parce que au travers
d'une crise et qui a été sérieuse pour
les familles concernées et bien le
parlement se saisisse du sujet pour
proposer et aller plus loin voilà je
crois que nous verrons quelles sont les
propositions qui débouche de cette
commission